[Music]
hydrogen is this magic molecule which is
the lightest most energetic and the most
abundant in the universe when you master
hydrogen in its pure component you're
basically having the best energy you can
have
[Music]
in the global shift to cleaner forms of
energy ever more attention is being
drawn to the awesome potential of the
smallest simplest element there is
hydrogen in this film we'll look at the
Gathering Rays to build a massive new
hydrogen economy which could transform
sectors from heavy industry to mass
transportation starting here in the
southern Spanish province of theodad
real
solar panels are being used to power the
biggest green hydrogen plant in Europe
it's been built by eberdroller the
continent's biggest utility company
the solar electricity Powers a process
called electrolysis
this uses electricity to split water
into hydrogen and oxygen
the hydrogen goes directly to an
adjacent Factory to make ammonia which
is used today mainly in fertilizer and
is widely seen as a potentially crucial
zero carbon fuel our molecule water is a
hydrogen and oxygen with the energy and
the green energy we break the molecule
so we get oxygen in one side and
hydrogen in the other side we take the
energy from the phototake band which is
actually four or five kilometers away
from here in puertoiano we take it and
we bring it to this building where we
have the electrolysis we have 16 cells
of electrizes there we we break the
water molecules we get this hydrogen
this oxygen and what we do is the oxygen
can be used for other industrial uses
and the hydrogen is delivered to to the
customer we can only produce in the day
so this is why we have the tanks we
store a part of the production so during
the night we can use that hydrogen we
have store and deliver it to the
customer as well the projects near the
town of Puerto Yano is just the start of
an ambitious hydrogen drive from bed
roller which plans to invest 3 billion
euros in this space by 2030. before 2030
we have different projects in different
geographies in the Iberian Peninsula in
the U.S in Australia Brazil and we will
see how these products are progressing
and it's not only about the hydrogen or
ammonia or methanol manufacturing
facility it is also about the
electricity that you need to generate
from Renewables to fuel all these
factories and this is also an
interesting investment from our site
hydrogen is already in widespread use
largely in the fertilizer and
petrochemical industries
currently nearly all of it is made by
breaking apart hydrocarbon fossil fuels
giving hydrogen and carbon dioxide that
gives off about a billion tons of carbon
dioxide each year two percent of global
greenhouse gas emissions for the moment
the green hydrogen process is more
expensive but ibed roller with a huge
and growing collection of solar and wind
farms hopes that will change pretty
quickly as the cost of renewable energy
and electrolyzers continues to fall
while the price of fossil fuels goes up
with tighter carbon pricing systems what
we want is that the final customer you
know the guy that is going to buy the
the bread in the supermarket does it
have to pay more in order to buy a
Prelude which has not polluted while it
has been produced so fertilizers of
course are a key element in order to
decarbonize the the whole chain if we
can take that money lower the price of
the king hydrogen our customer will be
able to sell more green fertilizers and
that money will flow through the chain
until the final customer that's the goal
that's the idea and this is something we
are counting on in order to make those
those that project fully viable
some energy experts have voice concern
that enthusiasm for green hydrogen could
go too far
recent Studies have shown that if
man-made hydrogen leaks into the
atmosphere it could interact with
greenhouse gases to worsen global
warming
meanwhile the world is already
struggling to build enough Renewable
Power to move its electricity generation
away from fossil fuels the more
electricity that's used to make green
hydrogen they worry the longer it will
take to decarbonize the grid
we can see that renewable is suspending
very much everybody can see that this
will also bring economies of scale keep
going down through the learning curve my
understanding it is that the final
solution will be green hydrogen
but green is just one color in the
hydrogen rainbow pink hydrogen also
involves electrolysis with the
electricity generated by nuclear plants
instead of Renewables
gray hydrogen is produced by splitting
apart methane gas to produce hydrogen
and carbon dioxide
black and brown hydrogen are produced in
a similar way using black or brown coal
the blue hydrogen process also breaks up
fossil fuels but in this case the carbon
dioxide is captured and stored or used
for industrial purposes
Advocates say this is the most promising
cost-effective solution in the near term
but critics argue that it comes with a
high risk of greenhouse gas leakage and
that it's being aggressively promoted by
the fossil fuel industry and then
there's Emerald hydrogen a concept being
pursued by one ambitious startup near
Hull in the northeast of England
[Music]
High Rob has patented a system to
produce hydrogen from hydrocarbons like
methane using a plasma torch
the process happens in the absence of
oxygen meaning that it produces solid
carbon instead of carbon dioxide one of
the funniest things we talk to people
about is your carbon footprint is your
CO2 your carbon dioxide footprint carbon
dioxide is a greenhouse gas solid carbon
ironically solid carbon is the lead in
your pencil it's inert it won't turn
into a carbon dioxide in thousands of
years so it's not a problem in fact it's
quite a useful byproduct it gets used in
the tire industry to make tires Rubber
and usable it gets used for Coatings
toner and so forth and then we're
increasingly using it in new cases as a
building material in cement or with
steel in the production of Steel and
other use cases
High Rock says its process can offer a
useful alternative to Green hydrogen
it can be deployed on a small scale and
uses less energy per kilogram of
hydrogen produced
and it offers a potential means of using
the world's reserves of fossil gas
without dangerous emissions of carbon
dioxide hydrocarbons get a lot of
negative press because when they're
burnt they produce CO2 but they're great
fuels they're really really energy rich
and therefore they're a great source of
hydrogen for us we've got buyers we've
got too many buyers and we're having to
limit the number of projects we can do
this year the investment behind that is
huge and fantastic because people see
the potential of our technology
foreign
out a full-scale hydrogen economy will
require vast amounts of capital and for
some investment funds that looks like
one of the biggest opportunities in the
world today
Pierre Tien from a former industrial
gases executive is the CEO of high 24 a
fund dedicated to hydrogen Investments
launched in 2022 the fund has raised 2
billion euros from a range of major
industrial and financial companies
including Airbus and Allianz when you
master hydrogen as in its pure component
you're basically having the best energy
you can have to be very clear if you
move into the energy of the future world
it's skin energy and it's a mix of
electrons on hydrogen whatever you do in
the future you will need a mix of the
two the only question is is hydrogen
represent 10 15 to 20 percent of the
final energy demand you have no choice
it's going to represent a big part of it
as a phone we are involved from the
Upstream to the downstream so we are
involved into the wall value chain of
hydrogen Upstream
um you're dealing with very Classic
Industries which are already using
hydrogen just need to shift from Gray to
Green so if you find the right schemes
with the right policy support you can
deliver green hydrogen at a price which
is similar to Gray
and then you will get a solid return
steady those projects are the first one
to start and you've got the second type
of projects which are more risky they
are far bigger they are more exploratory
but if they move forward they're going
to be extremely interesting in terms of
performance is the one trying to develop
this power to X
topic which is you do massive renewable
capture you do hydrogen you transform it
to ammonia and then you ship it to the
countries that need that source of power
which is clean and then the third one
which are the ones that are linked to
Mobility where you basically try to
deploy the networks that are going to
enable captive fleets and massive heavy
duty fleets of tracks of buses or
trains so we are looking at those three
types of our projects with different
Blended risky world but all of them are
very promising so far all of high 24's
Investments have been in Europe which
has been the busiest region for hydrogen
projects so far but prtn warns that
European policymakers will need to up
their game if the continent is to remain
at the Forefront of this fast-moving
industry
Europe is a little bit too regulated in
the way it process its knowledge but the
skills are there the issue is to have a
real
friendly business market system and this
is where Europe still has a little bit
of a way to go it's a fundamental moment
that we're living now but Europe needs
to tackle it very seriously because if
not we will lose many energy intensive
Industries and that's going to be a
drama
foreign
competition between governments over
hydrogen investment has reached a fever
pitch the EU which had long set the pace
for green policy is now scrambling to
respond to a game-changing move by the
US where Joe Biden's 369 billion dollar
inflation reduction act has offered
lavish subsidies for clean hydrogen
production
[Music]
positive sign that everyone wants to
become come neutral climate change is a
global challenge for all of us so it's
good that the US is stepping up with the
IRA Japan and others and hydrogen is a
key example for that low carbon green
hydrogen so in that sense I think we
it's positive that we are all working on
it and if the uh the U.S will step up
it's clearly also the EU will step up I
think 10 years ago when I joined the
Commission in the energy Department
hydrogen was a niche it was something
for researcher coming together it was
always there but it wasn't top on the
agenda I think that has changed and I
think it's it's a good momentum yeah I
think financial support is important
but mostly it should come from private
sector so there's a key role for the
private sector to provide enough funding
and and go ahead and we see a lot is
happening there in in the hydrogen area
then in order to accompany and have
cover the costs of the first ones the
first movers who have to pay a high
price we have set up a hydrogen bank or
hydrogen facility which is financed by
our Innovation fund with 300 billion and
this will be a starting point this year
to really do more Vladimir Putin's
invasion of Ukraine has highlighted the
risks of Europe's Reliance on Russian
natural gas giving new impetus to the
hydrogen agenda we had a hydrogen
strategy already in 2020 but with the
invasion of Russia and Ukraine we really
made very ambitious targets for hydrogen
as well in order not only to decarbonize
but also to become more independent for
example from imports from Russian gas or
fossil fuels
to see one of the most disruptive
hydrogen investments in the EU we headed
to one of the continent's northernmost
cities lulia in Swedish Lapland
[Music]
steel production accounts for about
seven percent of global greenhouse gas
emissions today it relies heavily upon
blast furnaces which heat iron ore with
Coke a carbon-rich derivative of coal
the carbon in the coke binds with the
oxygen in the iron ore leaving iron
together with large volumes of carbon
dioxide this transformation that we do
here at ssab when transforming both
luliocyte and oxalisone we are actually
reducing the Swedish carbon dioxide
footprint with 10 outside lulia ssab
Sweden's biggest Steel company and also
its biggest carbon emitter has built a
first of its kind pilot plant that uses
green hydrogen in place of coal we use
the same iron ore but instead of using
carbon to reduce the oxygen we use
hydrogen so if you take this iron ore
pellet we put it down in this process we
add a high hydrogen gas and then the
hydrogen gas reduces the oxygen from the
pallet and then we get the rest product
here is water and then we get a pellet a
sponge iron pellet as it's actually
almost 100 iron the only different thing
is that in this process it comes out as
a liquid and in the hybrid is still a
cold product so then we have to take
this product and then melt it down I'm
actually super proud of ssab for being
in the Forefront in this transformation
people were sort of shaking the head
saying that are you what are you doing
this is not the way you do it but now we
sort of we have produced the fossil free
iron ore or sponge iron we have produced
the steel from it and our partners has
produced vehicles from it so we have
actually been able to prove that this
works
ssab's Chief technical officer Martin
pay says that this process is now at the
center of the company's long-term
strategy it has already made its first
shipments of green steel using iron
treated in the lulia pilot plant to
customers including the automotive
company Volvo and it plans to start
full-scale industrial production in
2026. in the beginning there is really a
concern if there will be such products
on the market at all now when we have
shown that this works and a lot of other
companies are starting to plan for such
transition and we get a quite clear
signal that more customers believe also
that this is the right way to go for us
as a company we realize that we cannot
just continue without significant
technical breakthrough otherwise we
would be Irrelevant in the long run
[Music]
Beyond heavy industry one of the biggest
potential target areas for hydrogen is
transportation
the green passenger vehicles electric
batteries have become the dominant
technology beating out hydrogen fuel
cell cars it's cheaper to recharge an
electric car than to fill up an
equivalent hydrogen vehicle and it's
easier to roll out electric charging
stations than to create the complex
hydrogen fuel Network needed to support
large numbers of fuel cell cars
but experts see more potential for other
areas of Transportation where the heavy
weight of batteries and the time they
take to charge can create problems
hydrogen could offer a compelling option
for trucks buses trains and ships and it
might just offer a means of cleaning up
the world's most controversial form of
transport
[Music]
foreign
of all the challenges in the post for a
Greener World economy cleaning up
Aviation has long been seen as one of
the most fearsomely difficult but here
in the English Cotswolds one startup is
trying to prove that hydrogen can offer
a solution zero Avia has developed a
system to power planes using hydrogen
fuel cells fuel cells effectively
perform electrolysis in Reverse turning
hydrogen and oxygen into water together
with electricity that powers a motor the
company was founded in 2017 by valmiff
darkov a former Google executive and has
received investment from Amazon and Bill
Gates's breakthrough energy Ventures and
when I started the company we actually
looked at all of those areas so we
looked at batteries we looked at hybrids
we looked at sustainable Aviation fuels
bio and synthetic hydrogen combustion
even and it was pretty clear that the
combination of hydrogen on board the
aircraft
but going to electric motors so through
fuel cells is the best possible option
so and we didn't see anybody doing this
so that's how I started the company to
do it many airlines are currently
focused on moving towards so-called
sustainable aviation fuel which is
chemically the same as conventional jet
fuel but produced using plant matter or
carbon dioxide captured from the air Val
argues that this approach still comes
with climate impacts linked with the
burning of hydrocarbons in the air which
only fuel cell powered flight can avoid
so you don't have nitrogen oxides you
don't have high temperature water vapor
you don't have particulate emissions all
of those things actually contributes
two-thirds of the aviation climate
impact so if you just do the let's say
biofuels or synthetic aviation fuel saf
you're solving only a third of the
problem at the best and you're not
solving two-thirds of the problems in
order to solve two-thirds of the problem
or an entire problem you need to get
away from combustion and hydrogen
electric is the only way to do it
hydrogen flight is hardly new nearly a
century ago airships using
hydrogen-filled balloons crossed the
Atlantic on a regular basis but that era
came to a fiery end with the Hindenburg
disaster of 1937.
zero Avia says there's no danger of a
similar tragedy involving its engines
it's been testing its system on small
planes in the cotsworld where the
company has set up a large operation
thanks to financial incentives from the
UK government since January 2023 xero
Avia has been running test flights of a
20-seater-sized plane with one of its
engines powered by hydrogen
despite one earlier Crash Landing in
2021 in which nobody was harmed test
pilot John killerby says the company is
on track to meet all the regulatory
requirements needed to get its
hydrogen-fueled engines on the
commercial Market in the next few years
we're designing how we test the system
to demonstrate that they're safe we
won't be able to use this technology in
a commercial application unless we
demonstrate that it's safe
we worked the same requirements of
safety that that there are for
conventional known about powertrain
systems
and we as an organization are working
really closely with The Regulators to
make sure that as we progress they learn
and we progress together
zero Avia is in a race against U.S rival
Universal hydrogen which in March 2023
ran a 15-minute test flight of a
40-seater-sized plane with one engine
powered by a hydrogen fuel cell
valsa zero Avia expects to get its
engine for 20-seater planes on the
market in 2025 followed by 70 seaters in
2027 and 100 seaters in 2029. this is uh
the beginning of guilt-free flying
um if you will so that's that's when you
say hey I'm flying on sunshine or or
wind or any picky Renewable Power of
Choice different geographies different
types of Renewable Power but you can fly
on electricity you just need to use the
right medium to
pack that electricity on board the
aircraft and hydrogen is the best way to
do it
so what will the hydrogen economy of the
future look like and how quickly can we
get there hydrogen has the potential of
decarbonizing industry and transport and
that's our common goal it's good for
climate change it's good for
competitiveness but we also shouldn't
overestimate the role of hydrogen it has
a key role in certain sectors but
there's a lot more in the
electrification which we can do by solar
wind bioenergy for those and so on if
you can Electrify then do it because
it's the most efficient and competitive
way to do it but sometimes you can't
then we have another solution this is
hydrogen this is another root it's a
more expensive route not only in terms
of economics in terms of efficiency the
use of energy is much poor but is a
solution that we have in our hands
you will come in and you will have
majority of operations on the
non-combustion fuel hydrogen electric
approach where you won't have smell of
jet fuel the noise levels will be much
lower there will be no pollution around
the airports
and the fuel will be produced on-site
from renewable electricity I think the
hydrogen economy will be 25 of the
world's energy Supply will come from
hydrogen so if you look out 2050 Fusion
hopefully by then will be sorted we've
got hydrogen they're going to be massive
parts of what we do and we want to be a
big part of that as a business our
vision known dream and we want to help
deliver Net Zero as a planet so we want
to do our small part of that and
hydrogen is a great place to be
if you believe in the energy transition
this is the wave of the decade
and the only real risk which is not a
small one is that energy transition
doesn't come because for a reason some
people stop it or don't want to push it
with the regulatory Frameworks or the
policy support that are needed to make
it happen hydrogen may not be the answer
for most of the challenges that we face
in decarbonizing the world economy but
it's increasingly looking like an
exciting potential solution for many of
them
and the race to take advantage of those
opportunities is already well underway
this was the second film in a three-part
series please make sure to like comment
and share